it's friday and that means it's time
for friday follies of course joining me
now all the details
author of the forthcoming book the thief
who stole heaven
fox news contributor raymond arroyo all
right raymond
president biden held what they call a
bilat
isn't that cool a bilateral meeting with
a justin trudeau pretty boy trudeau the
canadian prime minister
uh this week and there were a few cringy
moments
yeah well starting with trudeau thanking
biden for his leadership laura
after the president killed the keystone
pipeline and thousands of canadian and
american jobs
but then biden tried his hand at a
little diplomacy
watch i told you mr prime minister
i took five years of french in school
and college as well and when i every
time i tried to speak and i make such a
fool of myself i stopped trying
at least when i try spanish and i make a
fool myself
they laugh with me
i'm not sure the french is helping here
laura
oh good well i think i i
he he's worried about making a fool of
himself speaking in french
i don't think he has to go over to
france to speak to make a fool of
himself
all right i think he's being a little
too grudging though because
um listen to the language when he tries
to say it in english as well
doctors and nurses wearing trash bags
over their ground over their
their uh dress in order to so they
wouldn't uh
uh be uh in trouble um and uh
they're uh um and you know i'll always
be straight with you
i said in mine i'll be give it to you
straight from the shoulders
laura no matter what language he uses a
translator is always necessary
i mean these brain freezes and the
garbled syntax
they do raise questions about where he
is
cognitively and i think that's going to
continue it seems to have gotten worse
since the campaign
he's in france that's where he is
raymond
okay i've got i've got to get to a big
story of the week lady gaga's
pet bulldogs were snatched laura from
her dog walker it's actually a terrible
story
ryan fisher the dog walker was shot in
the chest
by two assailants he is doing well
however who made off with a pair of
gaga's pet pooches but don't worry
the singer is offering a half million
dollar reward
for the return of the dogs the identity
of the shooter is unimportant
but the dog's half a million bucks
there's a term for this laura
shallow i think is what it's called in
the shalla lalalo
right yes wait a second she was
i mean i would be frantic about my dogs
but it must you must have read it wrong
it can't be
she it was the 500k just for the the
get the doctor no it's a 500 000
reward for the dogs not for the identity
of the shooter
which made my head explode when i read
this hmm
wasn't there a report in his son that
the lapd
was concerned that this dog napping
that it could have a political
motivation because she
sang at biden's inaugural and
is the fbi involved at all here well
well today the fbi issued a statement
saying they are not involved in the
investigation
but the political motive is apparently
not being ruled out laura which is
concerning
well apparently if you ever voted if you
voted for joe biden now and you
you know you you get stuck up or someone
someone robs your house it could be a
political motivation well speaking of
political motives
first lady jill biden sat for her first
solo interview
uh that was very probing from kelly
clarkson
she offered words of support for
clarkson's divorce
things are going to look better tomorrow
and if you can take one day at a time
and things will get better and you know
i look back on it now and i think
you know if i hadn't gotten divorced i
never would have met joe i wouldn't have
the beautiful family i have now
now laura the biden romance has been a
major storyline for a while here
the bidens claim they had their first
date in 1975 after jill divorced
her first husband but that ex bill
stevenson
claims the pair met earlier
i was betrayed by the bidens joe was my
friend
joe was my wife we got married in 70. i
introduced joe to jill in 72 right
before
the election in 72 jill
joe neil and i were in his kitchen
how do you forget that now
jill biden claims this didn't happen
that she denies this claim
but there are a lot of questions here
laura look people are entitled to do
whatever they want in their personal
lives but they're not free to remake
facts and reality particularly when
you're using it for political purposes
oh
and divorce should never be celebrated
it's always a tragedy
yeah well kelly clarkson i think i mean
next stop is 60 minutes for the real i
mean it's going to be a
real probing interview raymond i i still
want to hear
more of joe in french i'm going to be
thinking about that
all right pepe le pew act with jill
oh no pepe le pew oh
all right raymond thank you in